après des semaines d'intenses combats la
libération c'est en tout cas ce
qu'affirme le maire dira pin d'après lui
les forces du craignait non totalement
repris le contrôle de cette ville située
dans la banlieue de kiev
massonié plaisir nous avons de bonnes
nouvelles irvine a été libéré
aujourd'hui
nous savons qu'il y aura d'autres
attaques contre notre ville et nous la
défendrons avec courage ir pin fait
partie de l'ukraine gloire à l'ukraine
gloire aux héros
les ukrainiens sont aussi parvenus à
reprendre bâche tangka après quatre jour
d'occupation par l'armée russe qui a
tout rasé cette ville est située dans le
sud est du pays près de mikko naïfs ils
tiraient sur les maisons torturait
ça ne serait pas humain peuple qui dit
être frères un peuple qu'il ment au
monde entier qui ment à son propre
peuple il n'y a pas su par tous et que
dieu accorde sa miséricorde
à 500 km de là à kharkiv la deuxième
ville du pays
les pompiers continuent de fouiller des
décombres de l'administration régionale
24 corps ont déjà été retrouvés dans ce
bâtiment dévasté par un bombardement
russe au début de la guerre le bilan
n'est toujours pas définitif
la situation à kharkiv reste la même
nous sommes frappés par des roquettes
des groupes de saboteurs tentent
d'entrer dans la ville pour démolir les
infrastructures mais nous les combattons
et nous les vaincrons
ce quartier en périphérie de kharkiv est
bombardée presque chaque jour celtix fca
situé près de la ligne de front est un
champ de bataille de rares habitants
s'aventurent encore dans le quartier au
milieu d'immeubles dévastée